esta medida beneficia a los mercados
mundiales puede ayudar con la
estabilidad
principal del cap era tratar de que el
mercado no sufriera O sea que Rusia
siguiera a suministrando mientras que al
mismo tiempo se trata de limitar los
ingresos que Rusia recibe de eso
yo creo que empieza con un poco con un
pie cojo porque el precio que le están
poniendo es está por arriba de lo que
está hoy día realizando Rusia en los
mercados en los que sí vende Y todavía
tenemos que ver como reacciona Rusia
esto y cómo reaccionan la pérdida en su
reunión de el domingo bueno sabemos que
Rusia había amenazado con prohibir la
venta de petróleo a los países que
impusieran un precio máximo a la
electricidad a la energía Rusia podría
cumplir este pronunciamiento
bueno el que el que quiera predecir lo
que puede hacer Putin tiene que tener
ser bastante humilde porque puede ser
que se equivoque Este no es fácil
decirlo o sea ese impondría un dolor
financiero importante en Rusia Pero uno
no sabe cómo puede reaccionar Putin bajo
estas circunstancias bueno Y si el
kremlin cumple esta amenaza quién se
verá más afectado Rusia o las otras
naciones
los dos este Pero va a depender también
como te dije la reacción de la oferta si
la ope reacciona
a la salida de algunos volúmenes
importantes del mercado subiendo su
producción que luce como improbable
porque están produciendo casi todo a lo
que pueden Entonces sí tendríamos un
problema importante de precio y de
suministro en última instancia